roberto mancini's team have gone an
incredible 33
game unbeaten while uh 33 games unbeaten
quite the turnaround after failing to
qualify for the last world cup in 2018.
we're joined now by italy's official
representative in the uk
top defender one might say ambassador
raffaele trombetto
ambassador where will you be watching
the game from tonight
a good morning festival uh i'll be at
the stadium i'll be
stadium with the president of the
italian republic who is coming this
afternoon
and um i will be there with him and the
detailed delegation
i am so envious of you but before we
talk about the game itself
what's the mood like um back home in
italy
of course there is a lot of interest a
lot of expectation
uh celebration looking forward to this
this this much uh excitement all the
sort of things that also
people in england have been experiencing
in the last
in the last few few days and and a few
few weeks
but at the end of the day it's a
football match
we want to enjoy it we want to celebrate
it
with our english friends both in
in england and uh and in italy well uh
where do you say it it's a football
match you're implying
uh contrary to what the liverpool
manager bill franklin
once said uh you know it's
it's it's not life and death it's more
important than that about football
um is it as important to italy to win
tonight as it seems to be
to us well it's always important to win
an important match to win a competition
we have some experience there i mean we
in our h3 won four world cup
we won the european cup in 1960
68 but each time it's it
it's a new experience and of course it's
it's important it will
it does boost the morale of our people
and
we know how important it is now for all
over the world i mean for english people
for italian people
you know to have to have some very
positive things to to look forward and
to celebrate
um english football fans know roberto
mangini
pretty well from his time at man city um
do you think that there is anything in
the theory
that uh his time in the premier league
has helped him to become the kind of
leader
that has engineered this extraordinary
comeback
from 2018 to now where italy frankly
looked like a pretty rolled royce side
i don't know but i suppose when you know
you have experience
all over the world in in other in other
in other countries
other challenges of course that make
make you
you know grow make you feel better about
yourself
more confident so from this point of
view i i do think that the experience
that manchini had in england
uh have helped them uh i also
has been playing uh for many years in uh
um in italy uh but as i say you know
you you you take all the best from the
different experiences you've had in your
in your career so
i have no doubt that also the the time
that you spend in england
from this point of view has been as a
positive effect you know of his
experience as as as a manager of italy
um there's a lot of talk here about the
way that the team has
represented uh england and has in a way
brought
the nation together united nations um in
italy of course there is
you know and historic not division but
uh essentially there's not there's a
north and south issue that's always been
talked about in italy do the artillery
bring
bridge that gap do you think i mean is
the italian team
bringing italy together in the way that
we talk about the english team bringing
uh england together well first of
all i would i wouldn't really describe
it as a division between the north and
south
of italy of course there are um
different issues
in the north and south but the country
has been has been united
uh for for for many many many years but
definitely
the uh the national team is
is the team of the all of italy there is
no no really
whatsoever division even if during the
as it is here you know when the
when you play the the the the the the
national uh
championship the premier league or the
the serie as we call it
of course you know you have teams of
different cities so this part of italy
and this sort of rivalry
but definitely the national team is the
moment when the all of italy
feel uh united and phil no backing you
know our team
all right um ambassador look i i
couldn't have you here and not deal
with an extremely important question
which appears to divide
our nations um i don't think you can see
it
but uh we saw a
banner being held up by some italian
fans
which say which says stop
putting pineapple on pizza
well look um pizza is of course the food
of heaven
uh even the plain margarita is a
superior kind
of food but it turns out you know it's
summertime's got some funny
views about this what is wrong with this
humble fruit that i am holding up a
pineapple
why shouldn't it be a part of a pizza
of course you can choose whatever you
want to put on the pizza and there is
nothing wrong with the pineapple
as such but then uh you know
when you cook and when you prepare
something you always look for the best
or the best combination of ingredients
and we
we we since you know pizza is an italian
uh is an italian dish it's an italian
creation we know how to do it
and we don't think that with pineapple
you would taste the pizza
at its best then of course it's also a
question of
personal choice okay i i know you've got
to go though
actually the program is going to send
you a hawaiian
pizza just so you can see what it's
really like what is the score of tonight
well um my the score for me will be
2-1 to italy also because it's the same
score uh that was uh
at the previous important match
both the 1990 european camp and 2014
sorry the 99 world cup and 2014 world
cup 21 to italy so
i want to continue let's say on this
trend
ambassador thank you very much and uh we
wish you
the best of luck tonight uh and of
course
your team though not that much luck
thank you very much indeed